[Music]
how did you propose to your woman uh i
um it was my birthday
and we were having sweet we
rented out the back of this restaurant
we invited her friends my friends i told
everyone like hey if you have a story
like a fun personal story
come up to the podium and tell your
story so so a bunch of folks came up and
told like a funny
personal story and then at the end i
came
up and did a story about how we met and
all that and then i proposed to her
good setup too because it's slow builds
and yeah people don't notice
yes and you won't forget the date yes
yeah no i remember the day
my it's my birthday you better say yes
on my birthday
yeah well i have a story here of a
proposal that
went pretty bad yay let's laugh at
people
it sucks these are the best i know
especially when you see people proposing
like at big public events
like that [ __ ] makes me laugh every time
okay well i will tell you though
she did say yes okay okay she said yeah
so it went well
well at the end but the process to get
there was not very good
oh no the uh makes it more memorable
though
exactly yeah that's true oh they won't
forget this that's true
this takes place in the uk by the way
albert albert
he spent four hours setting up
60 balloons and lighting 100 candles
to pop the question wow after he set
everything up like a good two of those
hours were
for the candles and the balloons and so
after he set everything up
he went around the corner uh there was
also like
romantic music playing there was a
bottle waiting to be
uncorked just everything really romantic
right nice after he finished setting up
everything he went around the corner to
go get his fiance from work
and he shows up with roses so then the
fiance or like the the girlfriend she
was like
oh my gosh what did he do did he mess up
somehow like did he ruin something in
the apartment like why is he showing up
to my job
with a bouquet of flowers out of the
blue so then
so he's already a habitual fuck-up for
her to
[Music]
there he is again with all that
sweetness like oh
it's like what yeah oh god did you sleep
with my sister again
he must have [ __ ] up yeah so well this
is what it
what the setup look like very romantic
you know very spelled it right very
sweet
wait where is oh no is that fire is that
that's it okay
in a guy like their living room in their
place right yo he did 100 balloons
60 balloons 100 candles oh wow
actually 100 candles doesn't seem like
much yeah he also got that ikea table he
built it
and and yeah so once they started
walking up the stairs
to get to their place there was smoke
everywhere oh no the girlfriend was like
we need to call the firefighters because
our place is on fire
he actually burned the place down like
well not down but like
oh my god oh my god
he left the fire unattended yes
he's still proposed
so when you're in there does he just go
oh my god
he's like will you were you married
that's what he did he ended up
amidst the whole chaos oh she said yes
she said yeah probably he probably
played it off like yo girl
i'll burn this whole place down for you
yeah so that's epic she was like mad
really and not just that but they had
they just moved in a month ago
wow what if she's just used to him being
a habitual fuck-up like that's why with
the whole roses and everything and she's
just kind of like well
[ __ ] it that coffee table is kind of
invincible huh i know right that bottle
of wine that
ikea is a strong brand it's a great
company yeah yeah look at these glasses
they're
perfectly fine well um it looks really
bad but in reality they only
they had like some books damaged i think
like uh there was like three things
books some books dan the whole
place is burned down the whole wall's
gone if you're an optimist
wow that's how they're painting it
they're saying like you know they're
deep in dead right now their dead lives
are ruined yes
they're saying it was a laptop some
books and a speaker were permanently
damaged
but they do have like insurance and all
that so they're gonna look into
that table's not damaged that's for sure
yeah yeah
that side of london is destroyed
that carpet's damaged that's what
it's like and they said
just a handful of books and a laptop
like come on laptop a speaker and some
books that's it
but we got there's no curtain they
[ __ ] burned off yeah they're
like what are they saying i guess those
are the only three things that they even
cared about
to even mention but like am i gonna get
my security deposit
yes this is the outside oh god the
outside
of it so they live like on this i would
hate to have
neighbors like that keep [ __ ] up i
know imagine what
i don't know you guys are one to talk
because
that side entirely burned down that's
not an accident rattle these are
intentional
the holes i kicked it it didn't
it didn't matter your holes were
accidental
but then some other holes were
intentional so true
it was just like true i kicked it but i
wasn't intending my foot to go through
the wall oh that was the accuracy that's
the accent
right you know my favorite my favorite
damage to this office was when we got
your spear
and we pierced that wall oh the sword no
it was like a spear
thing oh wasn't it it was a sword and i
stabbed the the wall
yeah no i think you let me stab it and
that was really fun
it was a lot of work but why just you
saying when i got your spear
him correcting you you mean when you got
my sword and that just being completely
normal
that's this office yeah yeah i don't
know my spears at my house but this
actual sword
i still have it oh it's still here yeah
you would you like to pierce the wall
yes randall should pierce the wall oh my
god
and um we haven't destroyed the office
in quite some time
i know yeah it's been a minute because
uh
we like to we don't we're not we're not
that angry these days i think
i think before we were much more angrier
and we wanted to test
the durability of this that was the
reason why yes
and the wall it was also i think out of
curiosity where you know in the movies
like it could be like a horror movie and
you see like a knife go through you're
like
oh we should do it in real life yeah and
then we're stagnant through the drywall
because you know sometimes people are on
the other side of the wall and then like
the hero stabs the wall and then it goes
right in there oh
right yeah this is why i've been saying
you should always give idiots money
because they do interesting things but
yeah it's so much fun
yeah like that's why i want to do a show
where you give just idiots a million
dollars
just see what the [ __ ] they do exactly
gonna be incredible i think that's what
this show is that is what this really
does that's true
we're not stupid okay we're just curious
we're scientists
that's true we ask the right questions
you know how in horror movies and like
girls like that like hey put your head
against the wall dude
we almost did i believe i was involved
in this i'm so scared
no there was another weapon to it you
were testing out and then like i got to
destroy that wall over there behind the
water bottle
oh they had the axe yeah like a battle
yeah it was like an
axe that was awesome we tried to do this
one
where i threw an axe at geo which is his
wife
and then she tried to use my sword and
block it like the movie
oh my gosh and then she did block it but
my axe flew
and it hit that and it and that's where
the
spear is that's where it's because these
guys want to do things so legit
they had real weapons to do this because
that's way more legit
right if not then it doesn't count
i guess not oh my gosh but i would like
to say for the axe
i had a safety over the blade part
that is true he doesn't have that it
wasn't responsible
very responsible right how do you think
you would
um or i okay before i even get there do
you see yourself ever proposing to
anyone
because i'm curious what would you come
up with true
because like because your wedding plans
are pretty lavish was it
yeah yeah how would you want to do the
whole pirate thing
you've always wanted a pirate what's
your idea of
like a romantic joe proposal
um all right if i if
both of the girls i'm proposing to
were loving it yeah well first
i think that i would like to go to a
place that is memorable for us three
like if we met at the spearmint rhino
in las vegas like i would have to
recreate that kind of moment because
there's a romantic memory time
remember that night when i came in at 3
00 am
and i was down and out because i lost
mad money at the poker table
and you two came to me and really
blessed me with the best lap dance that
i've ever experienced right
right so i would have to bring them back
to that moment
where we shared that magical time
together
that's beautiful well then they'd be
stripping for you
well little john is playing in the
background it's like remember when you
did this for me
and i so like 10 years ago yeah this
already happened 10 years ago
well i don't know if it's but they
weren't strippers oh yeah that's a
little oh did you not know that
they weren't strippers they were
actually really respectable lawyers that
he met at this moment
so you guys were all judging they were
at a bachelor party i was judging
they're at a bachelor party
and then they gave me a lap dance see oh
they were bachelors no no no they were
friends at a bachelor party
that's just how down they are like
they're just so
cool that they got invited to the park
this is kind of hallowed ground in a way
because
didn't casey propose in this room he did
i proposed oh you did yeah tiff you were
right here i was right there and then i
was
he snuck up behind me with like what's
this on
was this it was on camera yeah oh wow
tim was actually
right there tim was there yeah tim was
like did
any did everyone else know
everyone the reason why i found out
something was weird
was because um i actually looked across
the the cameras because geo was sitting
over steve's and then geo just started
crying
and i was like what's happening what is
happening and then also
i poked her under the table i poked her
under the table with a paper clip
oh that's why she cried she didn't care
that you got engaged
that's funny no but like the way it all
happened was because
in the past we used to do these things
where the guests would read
the the beginning part and to be like
and blah blah news
and then read the headline and so tim
was reading
what he had wrote and so he was i forgot
in
love loves i forgot what it was in like
romance news or something i don't know
and then he started saying like our
history like our story wow
that was awesome that's amazing it was
really sweet and then he walked up so
they were hiding in
all of it oh gosh so so if she said no
oh no jeez would you have put it online
delete burn the cameras burn this place
down just like that guy did
did you know she would you knew she'd
say yes yeah together for four that was
actually our four year anniversary that
day
yeah we were filming the whole day and
it was already past midnight or almost
getting close to midnight and i was
texting i'm like oh we're still building
yeah yeah i couldn't imagine proposing
if you don't aren't at least like pretty
sure they'd say
yeah it's true but that happens all the
time because you see these videos at
basketball games
yes people like proposing and then like
the you know
the woman just like running like yo we
only been dating for three months
you've seen that i think we watched the
same videos my friend because i watched
one where the bear mascot was like she
walks away and then the bear asks
like
and then you see that he stays in
character yeah he is and then you see
because the bear boss goes like this
and then you see the guy like it does a
cut and then the guy's like being hugged
by the bear
i started walking him out of the stadium
or the other one where the guy hires the
actual sound people and there's a guy
with a boob
and then the girl says no she walks away
and the guy's like
he's like we're gonna need to get
another one
yeah no it wasn't clean it wasn't clean
i look how
professional those guys are
i know that's devastating devastating
you